ashish joshi uh reporting there there's
just some news now
on this billy gilmore story the scottish
midfielder who's tested positive for
covid19
and the fa are saying that as a
precaution at this time and in
consultation with the public health
england ben
chilwell and mason mount two england
players
are isolating after interaction with
the scottish player billy gilmore at
friday's match all three of them
chelsea players by the way the pair will
be kept away
from the rest of the england players and
wider support team
pending further discussions with the
authorities with public health england i
understand those discussions include
whether they will be able to play
tomorrow the entire squad had lateral
flow tests as the fa
on monday afternoon and all were again
negative
uh they'd said earlier that they were
the entire england side
tested negative uh the fa go on we will
continue to follow all kovid 19
protocols in the ua for testing regime
while remaining in close contact with
public health
england so there it is on the screen the
england footballers mason mount and bell
ben chilwell having to self-isolate
after coming into contact with billy
gilmore
after friday's match not clear
at the moment whether uh either of those
players mason mount or
ben chilwell will have to miss the game
tomorrow
those discussions apparently are going
on with
public health england so repercussions
from
the positive covert test for billy
gilmore
as those two england players both
chelsea players
are self isolating